COLT MCANLIS: In this episode
of Cloud Performance Atlas,
I show how a new load
balancer protocol can
give a big performance boost.
Will we walk the
performance high wire?
Stay tuned to find out.
As we've seen before, Google
Cloud's networking suite offers
reliable, high performing
services for your cloud
applications, things like TCP
BBR, network service tiers,
load balancing, CDNs, DNS--
the list goes on.
The gist is that GCP's
networking services give you
a lot of performance
with very little
heavy lifting from your team.
And that trend continues.
Recently, GCP's load
balancer added support
for the QUIC protocol.
QUIC, or Quick UDP
Internet Connections,
is a modern transport
layer protocol
that provides congestion control
similar to TCP and security
equivalent to SSL, not to
mention improved performance.
Most of the magic of QUIC
is concentrated on reducing
the number of round trips
required when establishing
a new connection, including
the handshake step, encryption
step, and initial
data request, which
makes it a great option in areas
where you see less than ideal
connectivity from your clients.
To test it out, we first created
a simple HTTPS load balancer
that serves a 10-megabyte
file from a GCS bucket.
Then we went into the
console and enabled the QUIC
negotiation setting for
the load balancer, which
allows the balancer to accept
QUIC connections from clients
that support it without
disturbing our existing HTTPS
users.
Now, it's worth noting that
much like TCP BBR, the benefits
of QUIC are best
seen in situations
where clients have
poor connectivity.
As such, to get a
true performance test,
we simulate a bad
network connection
using a TC command for both
our HTTPS and QUIC clients.
Now, on our basic tests,
QUIC saw a 1.3x improvement
in overall performance versus
the standard HTTPS on the load
balancer, which is pretty nice
for just setting one flag.
If you're interested to know
more about the QUIC protocol
on GCP, then check
out the article linked
in the description below.
And don't forget to subscribe
to our YouTube channel for more
great Cloud Performance
Atlas content
because when it
comes to performance,
every millisecond counts.
[MUSIC PLAYING]